at first glance jakarta's commercial
district looks like the centers of many
wealthy asian cities
a young and consumer-oriented middle
class has arrived in indonesia
but this group is still relatively small
a few people here are extremely rich but
most indonesians remain desperately poor
this growing inequality is endangering
economic development
the new president has to find ways to
create jobs
we're going to reform our bureaucracy in
order to make it more transparent and
efficient
approval processes which will be good
for businesses
that will create a positive climate for
those who would like to invest in
indonesia
indonesia
those are the words entrepreneur in
fahimah likes to hear
she has three businesses among them a
digital advertising company with 40
employees
she's been successful with it for eight
years and she's looking for
opportunities to grow even more
the first problem in uh
building a business entity in indonesia
is mostly about regulation
red tips
she's counting on the new president to
make it easier for business people and
investors
but she doesn't think the president will
be able to give everyone equal
opportunity
equal opportunities to me there is no
equal opportunity we have to fight for
our own dreams
narawi also dreams of success that's why
he came to jakarta 10 years ago
he sells soup and coffee on the street
surrounded by luxury hotels and shopping
malls
he felt there was no future for him in
his village in east java now he owns the
equivalent of five euros a day
life is hard here
if i miss just one day of work i'll be
in debt
small-time entrepreneurs like narawi
provide simple services which today
makes up 70 percent of indonesia's gdp
i hope the president will give us street
vendors more freedom
and we won't always be ordered away by
security people
for the time being many small business
people feel indonesia's economy is
passing them by
you